abandonar el acuerdo eso es lo que
quieren estos manifestantes en Londres
unas 30 personas acudieron a protestar
contra el plan del gobierno de enviar
los inmigrantes irregulares a Ruanda
pero el mensaje no fue escuchado por la
justicia británica unas horas antes de
las primeras salidas el Tribunal
Superior rechazó el recurso de las ong
contra el proyecto
siempre dije que empezaría con un montón
de problemas iniciales
y que tendrías muchas acciones legales
contra ella y que intenten retrasarlo es
inevitable
las acciones legales se redujeron las
primeras salidas hacia Ruanda en lugar
de 30 habrá menos de una docena de
personas en el primer vuelo de este
martes por la noche al enviar a los
solicitantes de asilo a más de 6.000
kilómetros el gobierno quiere acabar con
la presión migratoria desde principios
de añow más de 10.000 personas han
cruzado ilegalmente el Canal de la
Mancha pero los activistas de los
derechos humanos se levantan en armas
contra esta nueva política historia la
ultima que siente un presidente que
socavé el derecho de asilon qué les voy
a decir si me dicen ya sabes un país
rico como el Reino Unido los envía al
extranjero Así que voy a hacer lo mismo
el presidente que esto sienta es
catastrófico para un concepto que debe
ser compartido como el asilo
a pesar de las críticas el gobierno
conservador de Boris Johnson está
decidido a seguir adelante con el
proyecto tras un acuerdo de más de 150
millones de dólares con Ronda de su lado
ronda se prepara para acoger a los
refugiados al gobierno dice que está
abierto a su asentamiento permanente en
el país